let's just say you're an investor you
got a billion dollars you want to fly a
rocket into space and you're wondering
who to give the money to that can do it
cheap and faster better more efficient
you got Elon Musk SpaceX and you got
NASA do U.S government taxes who would
you rather give your billion dollars to
wait till you see some of these
statistics I'm going to give you on who
did it cheaper better faster with way
less money uh on how this goes and by
the way if you get value out of this
video give it a thumbs up and subscribe
to the channel and stay to the end
because I got another video I want you
to watch so now
SpaceX versus NASA who wins let me give
you some data when it comes down to
SpaceX when you hear the word Falcon
that's SpaceX so Falcon one Falcon 9
that's SpaceX they were looking at how
much it would cost to fly a rocket into
space well if you gave that money to
SpaceX it would only take 300 million
dollars to fly Falcon 9 into space now
NASA was asked how much would it cost
you if we wanted to do the same thing to
fly Falcon into space you know what NASA
said and estimated you ready for this
number not 300 because that would that's
what Elon says with Falcon 9 not a half
a billion not a billion they said
anywhere between 1.7 billion to four
billion dollars wait how can Elan do it
for 300 and you need 1.7 to 4 billion to
get it done it's kind of like saying the
following you go out there and hire
somebody say listen guys I need you to
move some of this stuff here from this
building to my house because I'm moving
I'm moving from one apartment to another
apartment right you go are some local
employees
running a small business that's a moving
business and so how much will it take
you to move this load and they tell you
ah we'll give you an estimate how much
it cost us about five thousand dollars
to move all this five bedroom display
counts five thousand dollars five
thousand dollars yes then you go to
another place that's run by the
government to give you the exact
comparison so you know how this thing
works you ask them same amount of people
everything's the same but they tell you
yeah it'll take us around 25 to maybe
sixty thousand dollars what would you
say that's the numbers they get five
thousand versus twenty five to sixty
thousand dollars three hundred million
dollars but Elon Musk one point seven to
four billion dollars now I said let's go
a little bit deeper so the guy should
give me some data on what it would look
like and how accurate the government
hits their budget versus how accurate
NASA does versus how accurate a SpaceX
is so let's look at this chart together
and let's look at some case studies and
we can look at multiple cases when you
look at Nasa you see a number of cases
at 118. when you look at SpaceX you see
a number of cases at 60 teen okay when
you look at average cost overrun meaning
if something costs a hundred dollars and
that's what we're expecting the budget
to be if it's ten percent that means it
ends up being done for a hundred and ten
dollars right you ready for NASA it's 90
meaning if they project a budget of 1.7
billion dollars it's probably going to
end up being 3. 3.3 billion dollars give
or take so whatever number they give you
pretty much double it now watch SpaceX
you know what SpaceX is if they take 300
million dollars it's going to be only
1.1 percent higher which is 303 million
dollars can you imagine the difference
imagine somebody come how much it's
going to take to build this house I
think we can build this house for 500
000 okay well you guys were wrong yeah
we're so sorry instead of 500 000 it's
going to cost us 505 to build it versus
you go to this company called the
government construction company and they
tell yeah instead of 500 000 you know
Patrick we're so sorry after looking at
it it ended up costing us 9.50 but you
said a half a million I know but it's
9.50 do you see why people feel
uncomfortable when the money's given to
taxes to see what they do with it now
watch this wait for this last one here
the last one is frequency of projects
that end up costing oh meaning that you
have to pay more for it nine out of 10
times with NASA the projects end up
costing the overall which is you're
going to pay the 90 and with SpaceX is
only five out of ten so again going back
to my question if you had a billion
dollars to choose between the two who
would you give your money to this is
where the conversation becomes the more
we raise taxes and we tax people to give
it to the government to choose to do
something with that money and then you
just compare a SpaceX versus NASA the
more you give the money to free market
innovators and disruptors will nine out
of 10 times do a better job at it than
somebody else that you're paying the
taxes to of course we have to have
public school of course we have to
certain things that we've got to pay for
but some of these types of things when
an Elon Musk goes out there and exposes
a NASA that's been around for God knows
how many years and SpaceX only been
around for a few years it gets you to
start thinking maybe entrepreneurs do it
better if you agree with me give it a
thumbs up and subscribe to this channel
I got a video I want you to watch that I
shot maybe five years ago why I love
capitalism whether you agree with me or
not I can't wait to watch that and tell
me whether you agree with me or not on
why this immigrant who came in from Iran
to Germany had a refugee camp to U.S why
I love capitalism I want to hear your
thoughts once you watch that video take
care everybody bye-bye bye-bye bye-bye
[Music]